وبسرعة مذهلة ، قامت الطائرات المقاتلة
بتكبير الصورة فوق قوة مهام الناتو
مرارًا
وتكرارًا ،
فهذه
طائرات ألمانية وألمانية ، لكنها تلعب دور
الطائرات الروسية في الجزء الهجومي من
تدريبات الدفاع الجوي وما
يقول البحارة والقادة إنه
بيئة متوترة على الجبهة الشرقية لحلف الناتو
تستعد لأي
سيناريوهات قتالية ،
تجري هذه التدريبات في
بحر البلطيق ضمن مسافة مذهلة من
الجيب الروسي في كالينينغراد ،
وليس من قبيل الصدفة أن يقوم طيارو الناتو
بالتحليق بميغ -29 وسوخوي 24  طائرة
مثل الروس تطير هذه
الفرقاطة الألمانية Mecklenburg VOR pomeran وهي
الرائد في فرقة العمل عالية الاستعداد التابعة لحلف الناتو ،
حيث
يقول ضابط قوة العمل إنهم يأخذون على محمل
الجد ، فنحن مدربون على التدريبات
في الوقت الحالي ، ولكن عندما يكون ذلك مطلوبًا ، يمكننا
حقًا القيام بكل مهمة  من
عمليات الأمن البحري إلى الردع
للدفاع عن التحالف كلما كان ذلك
مطلوبًا في لحظة قصيرة جدًا ،
تقترب فرقة العمل الآن من
إقليم كالينينغراد الروسي ، ولذا فإننا
نمارس وعيًا متزايدًا
يعني وعيًا أكبر بكل شيء بدءًا
من الهجمات الإلكترونية وحتى المراقبة الدقيقة
أو حتى  المضايقات من قبل الطائرات
والسفن الحربية الروسية
الوعي للقوات الروسية مرتفع
تمامًا في منتصف محاكاة
الضباط على سطح السفينة تقرير
الطائرات الروسية المقاتلة الروسية سوخوي
تقترب سريعًا من
البحارة الذين قاموا بمسح الأفق لرؤيتهم على
بعد 50 ميلًا بحريًا ثم
20 ميلًا من قبل  لقد ابتعدوا في
وقت لاحق عن اقتراب سفينتين حربيتين روسيتين
قادمًا على بعد خمسة أميال فقط من
فرقة العمل
مثل التحالف الدولي
مع سفن من البحرية الألمانية البرتغالية البولندية الإسبانية
والدنماركية والفرنسية.
الفرقاطة البرتغالية بارتولوميو دياز هم
أعضاء في القوات الخاصة البرتغالية
الخاصة يقومون بالتمرين على هجوم بواسطة
زوارق صغيرة تدرب أسلحتهم في
الأفق لمشاهدة وانتظار
مروحيات دورية في المياه ليل نهار
هذه تدريبات لكن الجنود
والبحارة أوضحوا أنهم يتدربون
ويستعدون لها  الشيء الحقيقي الذي يجب أن نكون
غير قادرين على التحول كل ساعة من
مهمة مضادة للغواصات إلى
مهمة مضادة للسطح إلى
نشر أه لنقل الركاب
للقوات الخاصة ، لذلك كل يوم تختلف
الحرب في أوكرانيا بشكل كبير هنا
تبحر فرقة العمل هذه الآن مع  ضعف عدد
السفن والبحارة كما كان قبل الغزو
وكما أخبرني قائد فرقة العمل أنهم
يمثلون خط دفاع الناتو الأول
ضد أي أعمال عدوانية روسية جديدة.